it happened to me on game change and it
happened to me on studio 60
i got these jobs because of the wives of
the
men directing them because they were
watching all the tapes and it was their
wives who were like you
are you you have to have that one that
one and they were like really
i wasn't sure i was thinking maybe the
other one you know has gotten down to me
and another girl
on both of those projects and
both j roach's wife and tommy shlomi's
wife were like the cerego and i just
think that is
i'm not saying that they were anti-me
the men but they were conflicted
and the women in their lives were like
there is not a con there's not a
conversation to be had here
this is what you got to do and i always
thought that was sort of interesting
these two big sort of
seminal moments for me that getting
studio 60 was a big deal they were all
it was the hottest thing in town and as
you said the licensing's fees alone and
he's coming off the
wild success of the west wing matthew
perry coming off friends has just ended
and it's his first
um it was a really really really big
deal and a lot of actresses wanted this
part and i was coming off as i said a
time of
really not working so i just didn't and
it was amanda
who insisted that they see me um because
amanda was also already
cast um and i had originally gone i
think i'd actually gone in for her part
before
while she was still being and they said
per amanda suggestion will you come in
for harriet hayes and
i don't think i was high on the list i i
think ultimately what happened is i
as i was told at the my final audition i
was told you had to come with characters
prepared like
skits in character so i brought my bobby
pins to do my juliet lewis impression i
brought my thing to do my this
impression i
and i did them whereas i think the other
girl that it came down
to uh to us did not do that so i think
maybe i had that
added element but i from what i've
understood and who knows if it's been
embellished or
member memory is a funny thing um but i
was told that it was christine lottie
who who was saying to tommy
like this is so i did in terms of
managing my expectation it was a
hard-fought job to get
and then you know i remember being in my
trailer thinking like oh so i should
probably buy a house because i'm
probably going to be in la for a while
just been in new york and i was like i'm
probably
gonna have to stay here this thing's
gonna run for six or seven years and you
know so it was definitely and i think we
all thought that there were too many
you know too many of the moving parts
were all these anointed
celebrated but look at the end of the
day i got to i got to
i got to do aaron sorkin speak i got
this i got to have his dialogue
like live in my mouth and come out of it
like it just it's it's
that's something that nobody can take
away no matter what you know
[Music]
[Applause]